[Musica]
buonasera a tutti io sono nata a gibuti
vivo in italia da 29 anni e sono
cittadina italiana da 10
voglio subito raccontarvi un episodio
per rompere il ghiaccio verso gli 11
anni tornavo da scuola e vedo mia madre
in estasi mamma che cosa e successo le
chiede lei è arrivato il permesso di
soggiorno rinnovato che ovviamente ero
felice anche io però per curiosità vado
a guardare il documento controllo che
fosse scritto bene e così sul documento
leggo legge stessa emma mia madre
coniugata con tezeta abraham
cioè io le dico mamma dobbiamo andare a
cambiare documenti perché qui non va
bene
lei subito sulla difensiva teso taioli
non ci torno ci sono andata già tante
volte sai quanto ci ho messo per avere
questo pezzo di carta per me va
benissimo così
e quindi io non potevo fare niente sono
rimaste al marito di mia madre per
qualche anno abbiamo precorso i tempi
delle famiglie arcobaleno insomma
questo episodio che quando ci penso mi
fa molto sorridere è solo uno dei tanti
che ho vissuto in italia e dopo 19 anni
e ottengo finalmente la cittadinanza
italiana
la cittadinanza è quello di cui voglio
parlare oggi la cittadinanza è la
condizione della persona fisica
il cittadino appunto alla quale
l'ordinamento di uno stato riconosce la
pienezza dei diritti civili e politici
il tema di questo tè da rinascita ma per
rinascere però bisogna prima essere nati
e il modo in cui nasciamo che spesso
viene dato per scontato non lo è affatto
e condizionerà le nostre vite
ho pensato quindi di portare su questo
palcoscenico le tante storie degli
italiani senza cittadinanza che nascono
in questo paese crescono in questo paese
lavorano in questo paese e vorrebbero
sentirsi cittadini di questo paese a
tutti gli effetti per esempio edward
christian timbri tv joe eduardo a 16
anni nasce a cuneo ha un forte accento
piemontese a male lasagna ma soprattutto
una passione i tuffi per ben 16 volte
sarebbe dovuto salire sul podio dei
campionati nazionali ma come dice edward
ogni volta che vinco diventa un fantasma
scompaiono letteralmente dalle
classifiche pur potendo state sul
gradino più alto del podio scalo
direttamente al quarto posto
niente oro per me e questo perché a
guarda il figlio di genitori romeni e
quindi dovrà attendere i 18 anni per
essere italiano a tutti gli effetti e
poter rappresentare italy all'estero
e così per un grande campione
le olimpiadi continuano a rimanere un
sogno ancora lontano ora tocca a great
nucky lei è piccolino a 14 anni ma vuole
in alto perché fa il salto con l'asta
anche lei è nata a torino da genitori
nigeriani ma appena la vedi capisce
subito che italiani stima tanto che i
suoi compagni di classe non sapevano che
fosse straniera anche great come edward
dovrà attendere 18 anni per essere
italiano a tutti gli effetti solo che
great la campioncina super un record di
3 metri e 70 e non sappiamo ancora se
questo record sarà considerato italiano
oppure no
il modo in cui lasciamo vi dicevo
condizionerà le nostre vite e questi
esempi sono abbastanza chiari ma edward
the great toccano un aspetto
fondamentale del del tema sono dei
minori e come tutti i minori sono
affidati ai loro genitori
ascoltando le varie storie mi sono resa
conto di come sia multiforme il percorso
che spinge una persona a richiedere la
cittadinanza italiana
dietro ogni documento c'è una storia a
sé
voglio subito sfatare un mito per
esempio i genitori di questi ragazzi
spesso la cittadina
la cittadinanza italiana non la vogliono
non la vogliono perché loro sogno
continua a essere quello di poter
invecchiare nei loro paesi d'origine e
questo sentimento di nostalgia in
qualche modo terrà incollata tutta la
famiglia e anche i figli che nascono in
questo paese che si sentono italiani e
che avranno molte più difficoltà a
lavorare ad accedere ai concorsi
pubblici a fare dei lavori che li
portino a viaggiare a fare delle
competizioni sportive come in questo
caso insomma ad essere riconosciuti come
cittadini a tutti gli effetti
oppure questi minori rimangono
invischiati in dinamiche molto più
grandi di loro
ricordiamo come fino a qualche anno fa
il lavoro in nero in italia era molto
più diffuso e le tante badanti che sono
venute a lavorare nel nostro paese non
hanno potuto registrare la loro
residenza
questo ha fatto sì che i loro figli i
figli di queste badanti anche se
nascevano in questo paese a 18 anni non
ricevevano in automatico il cedolino dal
comune che li invitava a registrarsi
come italiani se l'avessero voluto come
il caso della mia amica stella la cui
mamma ottiene la residenza solo due
giorni dopo che nasce la mia amica e
così stella
scopre di essere straniera a 18 anni
andando all'anagrafe per richiedere la
cittadinanza le possibilità per gli
stranieri di chiedere la cittadinanza
italiana sono molteplici viene cito solo
tre per non annoiarvi per l'adozione per
matrimonio o per residenza la
documentazione che devono avere gli
stranieri sono che gli anni di residenza
devono essere continuativi la fedina
penale deve essere ovviamente immacolata
il certificato di nascita deve essere
tradotto e legalizzato nell'ambasciata
italiana al paese di origine
questo fa sì che insomma a seconda delle
provenienze ci possono essere delle
difficoltà e in ultimo bisogna
dimostrare i redditi per il
sostentamento del proprio nucleo
familiare
la proposta di ius soli e gli sculture
di cui si è discusso negli anni passati
che è completamente affossata come legge
con la scorsa legislatura avrebbe in
qualche modo agevolato le vite dei tanti
minori che nascono in questo paese
crescono in questo paese e che
probabilmente a 18 anni si ritrovano a
fare un iter come gli stranieri adulti
per richiedere la cittadinanza
vi ho raccontato queste storie che ho
fornito questi pochi dati perché per me
è importante sottolineare che le scelte
dei genitori o gli ostacoli della
burocrazia non dovrebbe in alcun modo
condizionare le vite dei bambini che
nascono in questo paese o che crescono
in questo paese vi ho raccontato queste
storie perché mi domando quante
occasioni di rinascita siano state
perdute come nel caso di great edward
quante occasioni potevano fiorita ancora
di più o quante non siano sbocciata
affatto essere cittadini di uno stato
richiede impegno dedizione e sacrificio
e per me sarebbe bello che fosse data a
tutti la possibilità di sentirsi
chiamati i cittadini nel paese che
sentono proprio
grazie
[Applauso]